in that eventually the question is
pretty simple i'm giving a loan to
someone will i see the money back with
the interest or not
by the way it's not an easy answer but
at least when it's coming you know if it
was a good investment or not
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders i am with
yerev omel today the co-founder and ceo
of rego he brings 22 years of software
development and product management
experience and more than 17 years of
leadership of software groups and
companies
before joining rhaego yariv served as
the general manager and founder of
technicolor israel in addition he held
positions of head of r d at jungo
managing software deployed in more than
70 million homes
he also as the large-scale rnd product
executive at cisco and radcom yariv
holds a bs in computer science from tel
aviv university and an mba in philosophy
yadiv omer welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you very very much for joining me
today how are you good great thanks for
having me you know this intersection of
machine learning ai and
um and any new vertical that pops up i
think is is super ultra exciting and uh
and i'm really excited to hear the story
of of rhaego and your story of how
you're using data and and and really
interesting technology to try to
identify
short-term um real estate debt and
investing and it's a world that i know a
little bit about and and i'm coming from
the ai space and so i'm excited to hear
these 20 minutes how it unfolds into
into your world and so thank you very
much for being here thanks great you
don't come from the real estate
area you know as a right for over years
what led you to start a company
in real estate correct so my background
is tech i mean i'm doing taxis i
graduated at aviv university 23 years
ago
most of the time in telecommunications
and networking i started also a company
doing machine learning for wi-fi
optimization eight years ago
and a partner i have a very good friend
of mine he based in atlanta is doing uh
real estate investments for the last 20
years
and for for a decade is asking me i mean
how can we combine you know real estate
investment expertise on one head
software machine learning automation on
the other end to put them and to get a
better result really give some a
scientific consistent angle to real
estate investments
and when i after my last company
was purchased then we decided okay let's
try and do that let's try to figure out
in which vertical and how can we utilize
new data science technology also into
the real estate investment world
so we have to take a step back and and
you know a lot of people keep asking you
know why do we also need ai here or why
is this even relevant for the
why what is sort of the problem space
that we're dealing with in the in the
real estate world that you've identified
that we're lacking perhaps some some
some important tools to make some
assessments you so think about let's see
the market that we are active in right
so there is a real estate developer that
wants
to do uh to do a project right he
acquire a home rehab and sell it or
require land to to to do some
constructions and you need to find
something so think about the the
institutional investors that really
finance this loan need to do the risk
assessment right they need to decide
eventually if to invest or not invest do
they see their money back with the
interest or not and what tools do they
have today
so they have their archive xl model with
20 parameters that
never
almost never changed i interviewed
dozens of analysts in the last three
years i always like to ask them when was
the last time you changed your excel
model and the answer is
basically never and why
and why people are not changing their
their models because it's hard i mean
let's assume let's figure out i need i
think that i know a new parameter a new
data point that i think it's important
how do i know the weight do i have a
crystal ball to tell me and let's see
even if i have had a crystal ball to
tell me what is the weight of the median
household income or the new amazon store
in the neighborhood how do i test it how
do i convince investments committees so
eventually what is really happening is
that the investments committees and the
analysts are basing their decision or
personal you know experience which is
ultra reported
and mainly derived from previous
failures but not on consistent
data and algorithms so i just want to
clarify make sure that i understand what
you're saying here is that we have we
have all these parameters that we
generally know about right we know about
new neighborhood
status you know education systems you
know these are things that for for
dozens of years we've known to determine
you know a value
properly evaluation of a house but now
you're saying there's all these other
parameters that are coming in that we
should be taking into consideration for
example the proximity to the next to the
nearest
micro mobility station right i mean
that's a that's an important factor that
right now i'm guessing is not a
parameter in these in these hard-coded
excel sheets right exactly exactly that
and now and real estate analysts believe
that for example what you just said or
let we just added a new parameter which
is the mean time uh commute to work in
the zip code which is important but you
know
if you ask analyst how you're going to
model it he just don't do that so he's
deciding eventually by by knowing that
something inside of him right from his
personal experience or around the
investment committee table but how can
we take this experience or understanding
of real estate and model it with you
know big data stuff and
statistical models advanced statistical
models to a real decision making which
will allow him really to do much more
accurate and mainly much faster than
what he's doing today right and so
especially you're taking a lot of these
heuristics that we we are probably
bringing to the decision table ourselves
and we're modeling them so that and i
think the keyword here is consistency
and and you shared something interesting
with me before that you know if you take
a team of analysts in a given
firm and you perhaps replace them with a
new team of analysts it could be that
the portfolio is very different
is that
is it right or wrong i'm i'm a little
bit confused
by the way our investors so we have a
few very big institutional investors
that one of the reasons that they picked
us although we are more like the new guy
in the in the neighborhood and with less
track record this was exactly about that
they said that they said that you know
you need to have a consistent model
based on data that can be uh you know
evolve we had i mean we saw it by the
way by the way now we're seeing it what
going on and now with the interest in
inflation and we saw it in back in 2020
when covet hits everybody knew you know
unemployment is a big issue maybe places
that affect by tourism is a big issue
but how do i model that in a in a
scientific matter this is this is a hard
thing to do and this is exactly what
regal brings to the table a new way
people might say a smarter way to
underrate it and you know be adaptable
uh to the market so i think it's also
important to make the comparison here to
let's say to the venture capital market
you know
i'm i'm coming from the vc world and a
lot of people in following the show are
in the vc world where there is often
this sort of like this magic sauce that
you meet a founder and you say you know
what i don't all the all of the
statistics are saying not to do this but
i think you can make it big and you'll
make a big company in real estate it's
not really like that right you're not
looking for the 100x
on your investment you're looking for
some margin that hopefully you can model
scientifically correct correct and we
decided we caught that and i by the way
i believe from my experience that really
building it for equity investment is
much harder but this way we went to the
debt in that eventually the question is
pretty simple i'm giving a loan to
someone will i see the money back with
the interest or not
by the way it's not an easy answer but
at least when it's coming you know if it
was a good investment or not and i think
building uh
machine learning tools for that
is more i mean and you see it in in
other places you see it in consumer
loans you see the small medium business
loan sure we brought this you know to
the archive real estate investment
how did you decide specifically to the
to the short term real estate debt world
well why not
yeah first it's true we're talking about
or if people call it the fix and flip
world which is basically a one year or
two years long for real estate
developers to do their project we needed
there was few reasons for that first we
needed something that ends pretty
quickly because sometimes real estate
investments can take five or ten years
so
unrelated to the fact that you build
model or historical and you prove your
model on historical
track historical data you still
everybody needs a real track record
proof right where you put the money and
how it went and now after three and a
half years we already invested in more
than
a thousand loans 500 have been repaid in
full and already recycled without any
lost touch wood so we decided to go for
something that we can prove pretty
quickly this is one thing a second thing
is that we wanted to get to something
that is in real estate again because we
have the asset is pretty secured from
the beginning so we look for something
that when you develop something when you
build something there isn't a more like
unknown compared let's say for a regular
mortgage right that people take for 30
hours from their home if i'm building
something you know you you don't really
know the value after the rehab you have
like risk on the on the on the plan and
etc so there is a greater risk and we
believe the technology the greater risk
technology can benefit more so this was
the main tourism going that this
direction
what what is sort of the
the engineering process that you're
going through you're you know you're
you're thinking okay how can i
improve my model
and given the changing world what what
is sort of you know the
the the iterations that you're doing to
try and add more parameters or fine-tune
your parameters here so so usually i'll
take about three verticals how you
really improve your models so one thing
is about the data so unfortunately or
maybe the opportunity in our world the
data is
very untrustable unorganized
unstructured not clean so there is you
need to bring clean trustable order data
and so this is what is more low
historical loans that you know how the
perform you bring is better as more as
data points you bring is better as long
as they are trustable and you know how
to track them so this is one that we
have a team a data generic team that all
the work is bringing more and more data
try the data try the model second thing
is about the technique itself so we have
few phds in the team that they need they
try to improve the techniques should i
use a different statistical algorithm
should i tune the algorithm right so i'm
trying then every time i need to to test
all the kpis all the statistical kpis
and the third thing which is also very
important is the real estate expert
people that we have in the team that
give a constant feedback to the team
does that work does this make sense
and the combination of you know the data
engineers the algorithms guys and the
real estate people
sitting together on the same table this
is the real process the the loop that we
are doing in order to improve the models
right and so i think you're touching on
something that i'm that i'm also very
curious about which is this idea of you
know the human
human machine learning right i mean the
human computer interaction and
and it sounds from what you're saying
that the real estate people here have an
important piece of the puzzle
that it would be difficult perhaps for
engineers simply scientific engineers to
come and build models for this problem
without the involvement and advice of
the real estate sort of gurus right
correct even i mean we like to call it
here in the company like iron man suit
for the for the real estate analyst so
real estate analysts are good experience
but if they have the right models to
complete to give them as you mentioned
before consistency data-driven decision
that you know a lot of risk mitigation
et cetera this will give them powers to
decide
faster which is maybe you know the most
important improvement that we are doing
compared to others instead of days we
can do it very quickly and second you
know touch areas that maybe others are
not touching uh so this and again this
is built in a feedback loop but
eventually gives some we call it super
powers for the real estate analyst in
real time uh you know to react to
opportunities
right what what are some what are some
interesting things you found through
your through your work that if you were
to ask you know real estate analysts
five years ago whether they think this
would be an interesting parameter to
take a significant look at they would
maybe not agree with you
yes so maybe i'll answer in two things
one of them is sometimes a very you know
trivial parameters let's say the credit
score of a person which is a very
important of course parameter
usually but sometimes it's not maybe if
i tell you sometimes a very bad it
doesn't matter if you have a good credit
score or best credit score if you tell
it to a banker you know they will be it
will go mad yeah but how machine
learning works is about correlations of
parameters so we take 300 data points we
build a profile which is eventually
collaboration and correlations between
different parameters so sometimes or
usually credit score is imported but
there are times that because of
additional 20 other parameters value the
credit code doesn't matter at all and
this gives you sometimes it's very hard
for an analyst to understand that
because there is some compensation this
is one example one one sort of example
another source let's say and i just want
to make sure that i understand because i
think that that was fascinating because
we're saying that it's not necessarily
you know the example that you give it's
not necessarily that we're coming up
with a new a new parameter that but that
on its own
provides a strong signal for between the
zero and the one
rather it's actually a it's it's a it's
a
pattern of of the parameters that coming
together give provides some story you
know if it's exactly or coupled with 15
other parameters of certain range values
that's another indication
and that is something that we as humans
no matter how smart we are we just
cannot fathom because we can't have as
we can't hold for sure you cannot wait
them for importance so and this by the
way gives us a lot of ability to land
sometimes tomorrow or to project that
didn't get you know uh financing without
us so because you know some we just we
just like a week ago we found an
opportunity in a rural place you know
not with a lot not a lot of transaction
most of the institutions are never lent
to such places but it were like
additional 20 other parameters that
compensated on that which is still a
very strong deal and we did it so this
is one sort of way
which is interesting way
if you want more like exotic thing or
something like that we just added an
interesting uh thing we bought
there is a company that uh what what
they do they
they uh
calculate a quiet score how quiet
from noise point of view is a home okay
if you ask analysis i mean what does it
mean what do i care how quiet it is but
but we found that many times this
parameter was pretty predictive in a way
and uh and what we found out and when
because we wanted to investigate how did
they really calculated the quiet score
and then you find real real estate
thought how far it is you know from
roads from public transportation from
places etc which has real their real
estate stuff okay so sometimes you don't
get it but once you dig into it you find
it and usually statistic doesn't lie
yeah
incredible what have you learned
about the implementation of
of a data-driven decisions and ai into
places that previously
were sort of strangers to this because
you know the world is moving there and
and over time more and more industries
are going to be
sort of
integrated with with machine learning
and with all these different you know
mathematical tools
what what have you learned about your
own process of creating this integration
so
i thought it was uh
it's interesting i'll answer it in a few
levels so first i mean i think it's uh
at least in the the real estate
investment world is a very
you know let's call it archive so people
knows what they're doing they have been
successful in the last 10 20 12 years
things were good it's very hard to and
this is the real
core take an investments firm and asset
management right this is the core of
what they do it's not like you're
selling them
some tool helping people this is what
they what they do okay they decide so we
found it not easy to go inside and say
you know this is better this will help
you in your core really core asset value
of your company and it took us
i think a lot of uh
you know
took us a lot a lot to prove the point
and by the way also internally also
internally and also outside so i think
uh i found that and even sometimes you
know people and by the way to the other
side as well you go to the data sites
people write to the people that all
always only local data they don't care
about what is really behind it and you
need to convince them that sometimes it
doesn't make sense and i think the
combination of these two worlds
it's pretty interesting to see how you
can you know benefit from one each other
and eventually
proving uh you know uh
proving the models it's very interesting
to do that and see
you know
more and more
traditional institution investors and
essential you know firms that invest in
real estate that knows what they do for
a lot for decades uh are you know
adopting these kinds of new techniques
and then sort of the strategy with
rhaego you know growing it and scaling
it
it doesn't sound like it necessarily is
a traditional startup model where you're
supposed to see this hockey stick growth
but what is sort of what is how do you
position through
you know strategies and and where you
want to take this company
in this world we we look ourselves as a
as
asset
technology asset management company
which eventually we hope
to be to leading this uh asset
management in real estate debt not just
in short real estate but also for
mortgages also for short-term you know
like uh airbnb and others and many
verticals of real estate that we love
ourselves eventually the platform that
the money will flow from the
institutional from the capital markets
to the borrowers and to the you know and
all the and all the people uh that needs
to use it with a smarter and hopefully
more efficient a way of underwriting
so we're not going i mean we're not
really
have a sas model of this kind of fire
you're right about it we are more a
technology asset manager that eventually
help institutional investors to decide
where to put their money
fascinating and i think that again the
the way that you're looking at the world
and and i love how you understand how
fundamental you're really touching the
core
piece of their business right i mean a
lot of today's products and a lot of
machine learning tools oftentimes they
they go on and they provide features or
some insights that are nice to have or
they're secondary and a lot of the
conversations tend to be around okay but
should do we actually care about the
value that this brings here you're
literally changing their perception of
where to deploy the capital and that is
the single most important factor that
they're being measured on and and it
also sounds like the the way that you're
bringing yourself to the technology side
and your partners from the real estate
side
is a very healthy combination of putting
this iron man suit on the analysts and
so i think it's a it was a very very
enjoyable conversation getting to know
reagan getting to know you and and what
you're doing and and i just love this
world so thank you very very much
and best of luck with frago
[Music]